we never do not responsibility I feel
like I failed my daughter because I
should have saw different signs the
parents of our Kelly's live-in
girlfriend asriel Cleary tell their side
of the story Angelo and Alice Clary
opened up to Gayle King on CBS this
morning about their ongoing history with
the R&B singer and why they are now
scared for their daughter's life
the couple who appeared in lifetime
surviving are Kelly docu-series shared
how they're now 21 year-old daughter
first met Kelly at 17 he flew us into
Chicago we set with him in his studio we
met with him and he basically told us
you know yeah I'm starting tour you know
basically y'all need to make a decision
what started as a professional
relationship with Kelly to help Azreal
break into the music industry quickly
turned into something more causing her
parents concerned for azrael safety as
an underage performer the Clarisse say
they agreed to let their daughter go on
to her full-time with our Kelly after
she threatened to commit suicide
something she attempted once before
meeting our Kelly she says if you don't
allow me to go I will try to take my own
life again or I will run away mm-hmm I
don't want to call her Bluff on it
because I know she just attempted this
previously I'm thinking in my head she
only got three more months she's gonna
be 18 so she can do what she want
and she really carry out this and then
now I'm living with regrets for the rest
of my life at the time as riyals parents
did give written consent for her to go
on tour with Kelly under supervision of
Valerie Payton who was Valerie Payton
did ain't no Kelly it's not it's not
Robert Kelly but does she work with our
Kelly she pulls the work for the label
we found out later on that she works for
our company but at the time you sign
this you thought she was with the
music's only okay so you thought she
would be a chaperone
that's what she was supposed to been
okay mm-hmm and we found out later there
was no truth in it when Kelly spoke to
King at the singer denied claims that he
sexually abused or held anyone captive
why would I hold all these women their
mothers at fathers told me
we're going to destroy your career as
real also spoke out against her parents
they got very emotional and they wish
that their parents would stop in their
words lying on them they wish their
parents would leave them alone they said
they're very happy they're very safe and
they both love our Kelly and they are
both his girlfriends but the Clery say
they think their daughter is trapped and
they are not to blame for their
estrangement the perception is that he
preys on underage girls did that give
you any kind of pause whatsoever that
gave me pause I mean it gave me
awareness but you talk about a young
lady that's raised by two parents so
you're saying you trusted her I didn't
trust help what I trusted was I raised
my child right I trust my daughter was
will be honest with us and this was
strictly music parents on both sides
believe that their daughters are
brainwashed they do not think they're
being held against their will and our
Kelly says you know every time somebody
says that that drives him nuts said
these girls aren't tied down in the
basement and can't leave they come and
go as they please
despite as real and Joycelyn savage
saying they are not being held against
their will the Clarys want their
daughter home and they claim they've
heard the girls are involved in a dark
pact I've heard like a suicide pact you
know I know my dad yes I've heard all
kinds of stuff the difference is our
daughter had experience we're trying to
do it of course we will keep you updated
on the latest says these are Kelly
allegations continue the singer has
denied all accusations against him be
sure to subscribe to all things ét until
next time I'm Hallie Steven and I'm
Courtney teza know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]